you don't expect your kids to go before
you your heart stops and this do your
life seems to come crashing down in one
that's it it's ended
[Music]
the Lehman jack and Courtney and Natalie
thought be a good idea to go down the
beach would have been such a nice day
Courtney blew the dinging all of us got
into the water well to some the laughs
the the current was started he had the
dinky - too far out and they just didn't
realize and they're the start to panic
and that's when Jack and Liam jumped
into the water to try and swim and push
the dingey and then next minute we're
saying Liam struggling to swim
struggling actually his breath and I was
he gone down straightaway they call
water God it's extremely cold and Jack
tried to hold on to lay him as long as
he possibly could he just couldn't hold
on to million any longer and am
determined to say a jack let me go just
let me go see of yourself Jericho
and just seeing them go under the water
but fast
I was just swimming for help and
Jennifer Liam
it was always there for his friends and
if they ever upset he was there to cheer
them up I used to walk me home every
night when it was dark a very caring
very protective where I am used to
always give me a cuddle to say goodnight
well when everyone found out on Facebook
there was loads of messages from his
friends family our friends family I made
some notes his friends miss a lot his
family misses and notes and then just
miss him really but he'll never be
forgotten I don't want any other parents
or grandparents to go through what I've
gone through because nobody should have
to bury their child nobody and it's her
endrin
[Music]
my advice to people is if you see
anybody in the sea and the struggling is
to call 999 to contact your local Coast
Guard
[Music]